[Musique]
très
cool courageux intelligent qui va de
l'avant
dynamisme
[Musique]
passionné
alors comment il est il est là
les alors on est où là dis-moi et ben
écoute bienvenu à tous on est
aujourd'hui à
mrigac sur l'aéroport de Bordeaux
bienvenue dans la région de Bordeaux et
puis ben je vous amène au château moulin
de boss jour où je produis où je suis
vigneron et où je produis du vin c'est
la c'est la Dordogne c'est joli comme
cadre ah c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique tu peux piqueniquer comme un
peu à la
réignon qu mes parents ont quitté la la
réunion dans les dans les fins des
années 80 80 ils se sont lancés dans la
production de vin dans la région de
bergorac du coup le premier fou c'est
ton papa en fait le premier fou c'est
c'est mon papa donc ça doit être la
folie doit être
[Musique]
héréditaire ça y est on est arrivé au
château moulin bjour on est arrivé che
nous tu dis plus la case alors j'habite
au château ah non non non m dit toujours
la case bien la case on avait commencé
notre
vie à Paris euh Véronique et moi dans
dans deux cabinets de de conseil
parisien on avait envie de couper avec
un
cycle complètement fou avec une vie qui
n'était pas la notôre en fait bon voilà
un peu les l'exploitation les
installations
Thomas Verro là qui est là ma
femme je en train de préparer les
commandes àit partout la cuvé àit
partout qui est un hommage à la Réunion
à boire AC à cons mais ce qu'on dit à
consommer avec modération mais je ne le
connais pas celui-là modération qui sa
qui sait
quand je l'ai connu il y avait pas bon i
si il était fier de ses origines et tout
mais c'était pas tout le temps ouais et
plus ça va pire c'est mais moi je trouve
ça bien aussi parce que l'avantage aussi
c'est que mes gamins au moins il
baignent la dent eu ils sont déjà dingu
de la Réunion alors qu'il la connaissent
à peine la Réunion tu
[Musique]
vois
on est toujours comme ça c'est plutôt
une entreprise familiale une petite
équipe en fait pour faire pour faire du
du bon V de
[Musique]
qualité rentr dans la peau de
l'agriculteur là ah oui tout à fait
ouiens je reviens chez moi à la
nature
nous on
travaille de A à Z dans les vignes à la
fois pour bah pour de la taille jusqu'à
jusqu'à la la vinification et la et la
bouteille vin est un travail de l'homme
et ces choix et ben tout au long de
l'année vont caractériser notre
vin moi je suis de la région et c'est la
première fois que je connais un
réunionné qui est
viticulteur les décision importante
c'est déjà tout commence au taillage de
la vigne et après les décisions se prend
avec
Olivier pour les traitements les
désherbages tout ce
qui construit le raisin quoi dans la
vigne le vin n'est pas un produit qu'on
trouve dans la nature la la finalité du
grain de raisin que l'on écrase du jus
de raisin la finalité c'est le vinaigre
et en fait nous homme et ben on arrête
ce processus de transformation et on en
fait du vin un produit bah
qui
qui pour moi est synonyme de partage ça
tout de suite essay une stratégie de
marché la réunion ou pas ah non du tout
du tout on y a même pas pensé au départ
au départ on vendait notre
toujours à l'export par contre mais dans
d'autres pays on va des beaucoup aux
États-Unis on va en Belgique en Russie
au Japon à chaque fois des petites
quantités et un jour tu as il y a un
négociant qui vient moi un agent
commercial qui dit tu vends pas la
Réunion dit bah non la
Réunion nuront rien à faire de mon vin
tu
vois
tuas
et voilà c'est un système de filtration
à basse pression voilà donc le vin
rentre dans les dans la cuve tampon
pluie pluie dans les dans les gros
filtres là-bas et il ressort filtré et
surtout sans apport d'oxygène parce que
tout tout est sous cloches fermé et
voilà et s'ennuire aux qualités gustativ
du vin en Bordeaux c'est souvent des
grosses propriétés assez euh assez
anonyme si vous voulez voilà Monsieur
kadabaca c'est assez
est connu voilà il fait il fait
connaître son vin et il est présent où
il faut être
et je trouve que c'est une propriété qui
qui évolue bien malgré des années
difficiles qu'il a connu avec la Grelle
[Musique]
notamment on était là donc on a vu les
grillons c'était des gros grillons comme
ça tu aurais dit des coupe volante et
bah tu sais qu'il y a eu du dégât mais
bon bah la nuit te la passe comme tu
peux et le matin bah première heure dès
qu'il fait jour tu vas voir les vignes
et là tu vois le
désastre comme une injustice en fait on
a la nature a a repris ses droits à a
voulu nous rappeler que on la domptait
pas bah tu perds quand même un an de
travail donc c'est c'est c'est compliqué
quoi pendant un an tu as pas de revenu
donc tu sais que ça va être et puis la
réunion de nous a sauvé parce que les
ventes ont beaucoup progressé à partir
de là et puis ça nous a boosté aussi il
y avait des gens qui venz des réunionnés
comme je te dis avec des encouragements
énormes la Réunion comment il
est voilà untit peu toute la toute la
gamme
produit
partout vois dans les dans le regard des
réunonnaés cette fierté et ça ça me
booste à ch fois que je vais à la
Réunion ça me ça me donne un coup de
fouet et ça me fait ça me fait vraiment
je suis très honoré de représenter la
Réunion en fait Oliv il a toujours eu
très mal au cur il a assez mal vécu de
partir de la Réunion petit il a toujours
eu une ran cœur tu sais un truc en
disant ouais je voulais pas partir avec
tous mes copains ma famille tout c tend
C tend c'est sacré et puis c'est ses
grand-mères machin et du coup je trouve
que c'est un peu on en a déjà parlé et
dit comme si la Réunion lui avait
redonné quelque chose tuis pour la
réattirer là-bas et cetera après mais
voilà on a dit ben nous en fait on est
des entrepreneurs donc pour aller mieux
il faut qu'on ait des challenges des
choses voilà donc on s'est ralancé dans
un truc et on s'est ralancé dans ce site
donc voilà donc on a décidé de créer un
site internet où on vendait du vin mais
alors notre vin mais également le vin
entre guillemets des copains
[Musique]
c'est quelquun de jeune dans le milieu
viticool dans dans notre petit village
c'est vraiment ça manquait un peu quoi
donc ça a apporté pas mal de choses quoi
au contraire c'est de ça au tu c'était
oui c'est clair là il y a 225 L et le
tube ass doit y avoir 25 CLL
l'équivalent d'un ver ben ouais ouais
c'est je suis pas comment il a trouvé
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une super
idée quoi et innovante quoi le le
concept aussi parce que le vin c'est
quand même le partage communiquer dessus
et le fait de pouvoir goûter chez soi
tranquillement un verre de vin avant de
l'acheter c'est beaucoup plus mieux que
d'acheter en rayon et sans pouvoir le
goûter quoi euh c'est notre couple aussi
c'est notre famille les enfants euh bah
qui eux euh bah Contin continuent à
avoir l' continue à avoir euh cette
envie et et ça nous a permis de
[Musique]
rebondir c'est pas flippant
entouré de l'excellence comme ça c'est
plutôt motivant justement d'avoir la
barre
haute par justement ces ces Grands Crus
Classés qui nous entourent et ben ça ça
nous motive qu'on puisse progresser et
puis je pense que c'est c'est
[Musique]
bénéfique
ils ont l'énergie ouais et puis
euh ils sont agréables à vivre ils sont
ils sont bien quoi que ça progresse
et surtout qu'on parle beaucoup d'eux et
et que l'économie et le business marche
bien pour eux quoi pour la venir oua
qu'on a qu'on arrive à aller plus à la
Réunion qu'on arrive à profiter plus
prendre encore du du plaisir dans ce que
je fais et puis euh bah si je peux en
donner c'est c'est encore c'est encore
le mieux
à
[Musique]
bientôt